I'm having continued issues with constipation,
requiring at least one to two doses of Miralax.
Okay.
Well, we do not like anybody taking Miralax.
It's a really, really poor source of any of a product
to help with constipation issues.
So what's the best things to take for constipation?
Well, if it's just a mild constipation,
I would start out with just taking some magnesium before bed.
If it's just like, I'm not just don't feel like I'm having
bubbles, I just don't feel like I'm really emptying my balls.
Or if my issue is I have really difficult balls,
I have hard balls, then I would take magnesium.
Now, when you take magnesium,
you got to make sure that you coupled that
with taking an adequate amount of water.
So a person can be constipated because of many issues.
So number one, they can be constipated
because they're not digesting their fats
or proteins very well at all.
That can be a major source of constipation.
So how would you help support that?
You would take HCl and digestive enzymes.
So taking something like clear digest,
which has HCl and digestive enzymes
and support for the gallbladder, for the bile,
that will help you digest your fats,
your proteins, and your carbohydrates,
taking that with each meal.
That's a digestive aid with each meal.
So that's the first thing that I'd consider.
Second thing I'd consider.
Okay, well, let's say I'm already taking that
and I'm still having hard balls,
and it's difficulty to digest,
is start thinking, am I dehydrated?
So am I even consuming enough water?
So number two, I would just start increasing
my water consumption.
Well, no, that's not it.
I drink plenty of water.
Okay, then add magnesium.
You could be deficient in magnesium.
If you, I mean, magnesium is needed
for hundreds of different metabolic processes in your body.
So you can't really get too much magnesium per se,
because it won't harm you.
If you get too much magnesium juice,
don't put it into the bowel.
Then water is drawn because it's an electrolyte
and it'll help loosen your stools.
Now, some people will say I'm taking magnesium
and I'm having bowel movements,
but it's just really soft and it's hard to know
if you're really getting my bowels really.
It just feels like I'm not moving my bowels very well.
Then use this.
This is the phase six assist.
Phase six assist is a type of aloe called cape aloe.
Cape aloe helps get your bow,
your metabolic muscles around the bowel moving.
It really helps you have a much better bowel movement.
So if you feel like you're just, hey, let's say you went on a trip
and you feel constipated or you change your diet,
you just feel constipated or you just feel like I'm never
really clean myself out.
Take two of these phase six assist,
these cape aloe before you go to bed
and you'll have a really good bowel movement the next day.
This is not something that you necessarily need
to be on on a daily basis.
We do have some people that have had surgery out there
of their bowels.
They have domed, connective tissue in their bowels
and they just always have difficulty with bowels
that take this every day.
But for the average person that doesn't have colorectal cancer
never had surgery.
And it doesn't,
knows that they don't have issues with any connective tissue
or their bowels or any other issues that they don't have.
Any other issues that they've been tested on a colonoscopy
or something like that,
then just taking this as needed.
So it's always good to have some of this in your cabinet.
It really doesn't go bad.
Last for years,
and to take it,
what you needed,
would you feel like you're not getting yourself cleaned out?
It's Cape Aloe.
Take a couple of these before you go to bed.
With magnesium and with some water
it'll really help with your bowel movements.